je reçois ma temps la comédienne
virginie ledoyen pour la sortie en salle
de la plage virginie bonsoir ça on s'est
rencontré tous les 295 mais c'était une
première émission de télé première
émission de télé mais je faisais paris
dernière on avait rendez vous au
trocadéro exactement dans le froid il
devient grand manteau demande des fans
j'ai fait un peu mal élevé je vous
demandais si vous avez des sales
mjc tellement vous aviez avoué vous
fumez toujours autant
un petit peu moins mais toujours en
cours ouais toujours sacem avait un pain
qui était pour vous à l'époque
alors vous êtes là pour ce qui va être
apparemment votre premier gros succès au
cinéma mais vous avez fait beaucoup de
films la plage sortie mercredi avec
leonardo dicaprio guillaume canet robert
carlyle alors le livre des parents avec
bébés nous parlait tout à l'heure du
livre donc un livre d'alex garland qui
est culte qui est un livre va plus en
angleterre dire qu'aux états unis qui
est sorti en france c'est hachette
littératures alors vous l'avez lue après
avoir accepté ou avant après après un
très j'en avais pas du tout entendu
parler en fait et parce qu'effectivement
ça a été un best-seller en angleterre je
cours aux états unis mais en france je
ne savais pas et ouais si les jeux après
c'est pas très différent parce que le
film est différent du passé dans le film
quand même non c'est pas aseptisé mais
c'est toute façon de ce qui est écrit
dans le bouquin c'est un film à blond il
ya des choses qui sont pas qu'ils sont
pas filmés c'est pour ça que c'est un
film est pas un livre alors le pitch
comme on dit ici donc richard rencontre
françoise quitte avec etienne à bangkok
dans un hôtel pourri comme on en
connaissait à l'époque et ils vont dans
cette danse est il quoique d'une espèce
de baba landes
vous continuez qu'est ce qui se passe
une fois là bas mais une fois là-bas
d'abord c'est très compliqué d'y aller
ouais et puis ensuite ils finissent
finalement par y arriver et c'est assez
fantastique c'est vrai que c'est cool
c'est bien ils sont tous gentils
tout ce beau
et puis finalement c'est pas si bien que
ça
et finalement oui évidemment c'est le
paradis qui se transforme en enfer ou
alors ou alors c'est un apprentissage eu
de démarche un peu initiatique oui
complètement je laisserai elisabeth qu'à
nous faire la psychanalyse du film en
tout cas moi j'ai trouvé ça très bien
alors le réalisateur c'est danny boyle
café petits meurtres entre amis les
trainspotting là qu'il ya une s'est un
peu calmé quand même sur ce film ouais
mais je trouve que gili a un peu c'est
moins spectaculaire mais c'est en corse
et il ya toujours ce cynisme oui c'est
assez incisif malgré tout je crois que
hollywood ya un produit par la fox c'est
quand même assez incisif le casting se
contente jamais de ça en fait à la télé
c'est à dire quand on vous voit arriver
vous les actrices comme ça on dirait du
pot ale temps avec dicaprio ou est-elle
en thaïlande pour moi en fait bon il ya
eu un moment où nous étions en
concurrence contre d'autres actrices
j'imagine on n'en parle jamais de sa
williams palpable c'était un casting il
est venu à part leur rencontre et il
connaît pas nécessairement très bien les
actrices françaises donc il est venu et
puis et puis on se voit puis on fait des
essais une première fois puis une
seconde fois puis on attend puissent
apprendre la semaine et puis on
recommence on vient et puis et puis on
vous saviez que vous savez qu'il était
en concurrence contre vous non non pas
parce que présente pour les roseaux
sauvages vous et c'est sur le coup vous
arrêtez ça c'est le dit bush s p gagné
non mais c'est terrible on se rend pas
compte en fait ça doit être des moments
terribles en vous je crois que là vous
vous tellement vous aviez le travail est
parti mais je me suis cassé il en a tant
pis et puis on vous a appelé
pratiquement le lendemain vous disant
cette menace est parce que c'est vrai
que ça prend beaucoup d'importance et
puis en même temps on n'est pas on n'est
pas nécessairement le personnage mais on
est le personnage l'actrice que le
metteur en scène ravi d'avoir mais quand
on sait qu'il ya il voit cinq filles s'y
fit sans même savoir qui elles sont ça
devient très compliqué est ce que c'est
moi est-ce que c'est pas moi et donc ça
rend con
alors au niveau du cash chez vous a été
bien payé pour faire ça ouais ça va ça
va leonardo il a pris un paquet lui
quand même
leonardo il a pris la moitié du budget
du film 20 millions de dollars sur 50
millions de dollars c'est bien il vole
un peu quand même mais vous en aller
simple we can pas les millions de
dollars comme lui non ça me suffit
amplement et là c'est bien là c'est bien
parti alors ben quand je parlais du buzz
qu'a eu sur le film tout à l'heure c'est
le tournage donc cette île au large de
phuket avec tout le monde connaît
l'histoire de la production voulait a
voulu raser des dunes a voulu replanter
des cocotiers
jeu mais trop sale histoire en fait ils
ont trouvé cette île qui pipe il y était
une poubelle en fait si je voulais
qu'elle soit complètement encadré de
rochers elle était dégueulasse il vous
fait nettoyés ils ont replanté des
palmiers et les écologistes locaux
étaient pas contents certains en fait
c'était une partie était d'accord et
suivait le tournage contrôler tout ce
qui se passe est une autre qui les et le
fait que ce soit la fox et surtout
dicaprio pour faire une pub monstrueuse
autour de soi tout a été remis en état
oui un oeil aux champs de cannabis moi
ce qui m'a plus fasciné je veux dire il
a été planté ce champ de cannabis il
était gigantesque
alors on nous a dit que ce n'était pas
à bord feuilles de cannabis avant j'en
doute mais la personne n'a essayé quand
même
alors il était éclairé 18 heures par
jour pour que ça pousse plus vite bah
c'est un cours comme ça maintenant on
sait comment il faut faire pour faire
dans son jardin il faut mettre 1000 en
pleine nuit par exemple bien alors vous
dit en parlant de vous que vous n'êtes
pas une bonne affaire pour les
journalistes et pour la presse vite moi
je suis heureuse j'ai eu une enfance
heureuse chape ennuyeuse pour la pour la
presse c'est un peu sans histoire d'une
certaine façon
on essaye de vous mettre un peu une
image de deux petites origines modestes
on vous le fait le coup parce que vous
êtes né à aubervilliers mais votre père
venait de la dass il travaillait sur les
marchés
grand-mère concierge en éditions valor
voilà qu'à la suite on recherche des
étiquettes tout le monde cherche
toujours des étiquettes donc les
journalistes essayent de vous mettre un
peu dans cette catégorie mais vous dites
je ne suis pas cause est bien que tout
le tourner avec josé d'ailleurs mais non
non c'est à dire que c'est pas
spectaculaire j'ai pas ce qui est ce qui
relève de mon intimité samara ça m'amuse
pas de la raconter j'ai des parents que
j'adore qui ont été formidable avec moi
qui sont commis sont effectivement je
finis aubervilliers voilà plus jolies
villes de france mais c'est enfin bon
vous étiez gâtés comme j'étais petit je
n'étais pas spécialement malheureuse jet
ski tout va bien je partais à méribel
vous avez des origines sachet est
positive origines métissées du sang
espagnol espagnol noir qui a dissous son
nom et espagnols alors j'imagine
j'imagine probablement arabe
mais non j'ai des tentes
j'ai deux tantes d'origine malienne oui
des cousins en cabine enfin je sais pas
mais l'enjeu sera donc avec les gens de
partout alors y'a un truc plus
intéressant c'est que non merci non mais
j'ai plus intéressant sur le rapport aux
origines modestes vous concernant c'est
à dire que fabrice luchini michel
serrault m'ont raconté ici que ce qui
avait été leur meilleure école de
comédie c'était la rue c'est venu jeudi
plus intéressant puisque vous à l'âge de
15 ou 16 ans vous étiez sur les marchés
avec votre père et vous quand vous
parlez de vie vous dites c'était la
commedia dell'arte la façon qu'ils
avaient de vendre aux anciens mais ça
vous a inspiré ça je sais pas si ça m'a
certainement mais je trouvais ça
fascinant que le pouvoir de persuasion
que de marcher dans la rue d'avoir un
mec qui est là qui vous qui vous appelle
et décide de vous vendre un truc donc
vous n'avez peut-être pas besoin
nécessairement et vous repartirez avec
et je trouve que c'est un pouvoir de
persuasion fou la lucchini 0 c'est ça
oui à la paix il se balader dans la rue
là bas vershbow mon mari il faisait le
conte dans la rue ce héros aussi c'est
comme ça c'est au contact de la rue
qu'ils ont appris à jouer la comédie
quoi je pensais alors vous avez débuté à
l'âge de 3 ans dans des pubs
oui dans des pubs mais une pub je sais
pas une finale non non non je me
souviens pas bien j'ai fait des photos
mais c'était c'était le truc
occasionnait j'ai dû faire de pub entre
3 ans et six ans après l'âge de 9 ans et
aide à l'école du spectacle exactement
et à 16 ans est partie de chez vous avez
commencé à mener votre vie à l'âge de 16
ans mais c'est bien je ne sais pas j'ai
pas nouveau c'était bien parce que
c'était ce que j'avais envie mais j'ai
beau parent n'était pas inquiet je pense
qu'il l'était mais en tout cas ils ont
fait comme s'ils trouvaient c'est
absolument normal non parce que votre
premier casting enfin sérieux là c'était
minima avec philomène esposito vous êtes
allé tout seul âge de 13 ans au casting
alors que toutes les petites filles et
avec leur maman oui mais je connais
métro pour l école tout seul partage de
huit ans dont elle est un casting pas
que mes parents trouvé ça très bien je
pense qu'il était très fier mais en même
temps je n'ai pas non plus envie de
passer leur vie à me chaperonner
m'accompagner au casting et c'est donc
si jamais vous retournez chez vous vous
dites voilà je vais faire un film à la
patrie
alors il a fallu que la production
atteigne mes parents pour dire que
c'était vrai c'est assez volontariste
quand même quand voulais un truc oui moi
je trouve que je n'ai pas l'impression
de pouvoir faire les choses tout seul
mais tout cas j'essaye de me donner les
moyens de les faire donc ça marche pas
toujours j'essaie femmes et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux